they are the people society fears most a
world of violence and coercion gang wars
and bloody riots it's an entire nation
behind bars a prison nation with numbers
rising gangs serve as the biggest threat
to inmates and officers gangs virtually
run the prisons whatever the generals
say that's what goals they're a complex
organization a secret society within the
prison system and loyalty is everything
when you come to prison you can either
join a prison gang
[Music]
boarded alone
if you are alone then you can fall prey
to anybody
most often inmates band together along
racial and ethnic lines right here you
have the northern African blacks you
have you have the Crips Bloods you're
the for15 you have the white boys most
of them will probably lean towards the
Nazi lowrider so the NL arm or the Aryan
Brotherhood ad to survive you have to
stand by your own you have to fight to
protect them even if it means putting
your life in jeopardy folks in here
aren't out for your best interests at
heart you know what I mean you decide
this is the jungle one you're gonna have
to find a way to survive when the word
comes down from the leaders the gang
members respond with brutal and violent
acts including beatings riots or even
homicide if we put a hit on somebody
we basically want them life flighted
they said a statement for the whole
institutional investment scripts so in a
world so tough what is being done to try
and turn these gang members around
creating because everybody in here is
you know for the most part most of them
you know will hit the streets again we
need to give them the ability to
rehabilitate themselves prisons across
America are working to provide a variety
of programs to help rehabilitate
convents re-entry programs job training
and substance abuse programs help the
inmates to take responsibility for their
actions they're also getting the chance
to get a higher education
just putting on this Romanus in fact I
couldn't even sleep last I was on the
Dean's this Wow I didn't even know what
the Dean's miss was I thought I did
something wrong
took five classes they've got five days
in Commons we know from all the research
that the more education you have when
you leave prison the better off you'll
be
especially if you can manage to get any
kind of college education if the inmates
take advantage of these opportunities
their life has the potential to turn
around good life you know that know with
the picket fence you know what I'm
but sometimes the violence of prison is
too much for success everyone goes into
prison comes out of it and if they come
out worse than when they went in if they
come out angry or
because what you did was warehouse them
you didn't do anything just kept them
sort of alone and isolated again they're
going to commit violence because why
isn't this year half of all the people
now in prison will be released
ironically enough the majority of those
who get out end up right back inside
this prison nation